I believe we have a choice in this world
about how to tell sad stories on the one
hand you can sugarcoat it on nothing is
too messed up that can't be fixed with a
Peter Gabriel song I like that version
as much as the next girl does it's just
not the truth this is the truth doctor's
appointments reality shows worst of all
support group Christ is our friend and
he'll do that to him alright hazel how
are you doing
you mean besides the cancer alright hey
yes why don't I play another song you
need to be a teenager you want me to be
a teenager you don't send me to support
group gotta give me a fake ID so that I
can go to clubs and take pot uh don't
take Paulette that is the kind of thing
I would know with a fake ID hey make
some friends sorry I'm Ben I'm Augustus
waters I've been in remission for about
a year and a half maybe you'd like to
share some of your fears with the group
living what's your name hazel why
spinning me busy beautiful
really you just ruin this whole thing
the whole thing yes this whole thing oh
man you're doing really well too I never
lit one hmm it's a metaphor see you put
the thing that does the killing right
between your teeth but you never give it
the power to kill you
I'm metaphor so what's your story
who's diagnosed nurse there oh yeah your
cancer story your real story your
hobbies your passions your weird
fetishes I am quite unexpected at of a
hand you know Gus talks about you all
the time
we're just friends you trying to keep
your distance for me in no way lessens
my affection for you Gus I'm a grenade
one day I'm gonna blow up and I'm gonna
butter everything in my wake and I don't
want her
you don't get to choose if you get hurt
in this world but you do have a say in
who hurts you I am in love with you
hazel grace and I know that love is just
a shout into the void and that oblivion
is inevitable and I am in love with you
only reference to keep me from you're
gonna fail
are you angry so England you need to
break something
I fell in love with him the way you fell
asleep
slowly when we not what it's a good life
hazel grace okay
okay